[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you're very welcome to join us
wherever you're watching us around the
world this morning a new day has dawned
but it feels like we're waking up to a
very similar tone warnings from world
leaders to russia not to invade ukraine
and another day of diplomacy planned but
will it be enough to bring the situation
back from the brink with the west
fearing an attack could be imminent
we'll ask the foreign secretary liz
trust shortly as well as the former head
of the british army general lord danette
it is tuesday the 15th of february
fears that russia's president putin
could order an attack at any time as the
ukrainian president calls on politicians
who've left saying it's their duty to
return to protect his homeland
border tensions as russian troops train
in belarus we'll analyze what an
invasion of ukraine could look like and
where nato holds positions
and i'm live in moscow where president
putin is preparing to meet with the
german chancellor but our diplomatic
hopes fading
and prices at the pumps what are you
paying for your fuel today and why is
does that reflect with what's happening
in the ukraine
skating around the controversy the
russian teenager who's been cleared to
compete in the winter olympics following
a doping allegation prepares to take to
the ice we are live in beijing
[Music]
that's your earworm this morning ladies
and gentlemen which uk sites are on your
bucket list we'll take you through the
spots from around the country that have
come out on top with the telegraph
travel editor claire oven
also on the programme for you this
morning is it a bird
is it a plane
no it's a flying car i'm going to be
speaking to the founder of a company
that's just begun taking orders
for that vehicle
apparently anyone can drive or fly it
depending on which way you're looking at
and also in the driving seat we meet the
young woman inspired to train as a lorry
driver following brexit shortages after
a career
as a beauty queen
[Music]
we love that how sassy is she a very
good morning to you there is still a
crucial window for diplomacy that was
the message from boris johnson and joe
biden last night as they said there was
still time for vladimir putin to step
back from impending war in ukraine but
today the german chancellor will travel
to moscow to meet the russian president
vladimir putin olaf schultz says there
are no sensible reasons for the buildup
of more than 130 000 troops on ukraine's
borders
let's take a look at the key points
you're waking up to this morning
german chancellor olaf schultz will hold
talks with president putin in moscow
this morning
in the uk the prime minister will chair
an emergency meeting of the cobra
committee boris johnson is also expected
to travel to europe later this week to
step up uk's diplomatic efforts
meanwhile there are warnings of a
humanitarian crisis with ukrainian
refugees going over the border to places
like poland this morning russia's
foreign minister sergey lavrov will meet
his polish counterpart
it comes as ukraine's president declared
that tomorrow's a day of unity calling
on ukrainians to fly the country's flag
and sing the national anthem in unison
ukrainian people entrusted you with
governing the state as well as defending
it
it is your direct duty in such a
situation to be with us with the
ukrainian people
i suggest that you return to your
homeland within 24 hours
and stand shoulder to shoulder with the
ukrainian army our diplomats and our
people
well diana's standing by for us in
moscow this morning hello to you um
diana it feels a little bit like
groundhog day how close are we to
stepping back or indeed to stepping
further forward
well the kremlin signaled yesterday that
they wanted to keep talking now they
could be going on two tacks they have
done all along they've talked about
pursuing the diplomatic path and that
they want to see progress made on their
security guarantee proposals whilst also
building up troops at the border and as
the west has said continually we want to
see actions rather than words
but we have olaf scholz the german
chancellor coming today he's the third
eu leader to come and visit vladimir
putin really in the last 10 days or so
we had emmanuel macron we had victor
orban we had now we have now olaf
schultz all of whom are bringing a
message of resolve and unity and tough
sanctions should
president putin choose to invade ukraine
thanks diana i'm pleased to say that the
foreign secretary liz truss is with us i
know you're incredibly busy so we really
appreciate you taking the time thank you
quick um thoughts on uh things like the
fact that we've heard words like
imminent
and likely regarding uh an invasion
where are we this tuesday morning as
you're concerned well it's still the
case that an invasion could be imminent
and it is highly likely what we are
doing is pursuing the path of deterrence
and diplomacy
urging vladimir putin to step back from
the brink he currently has a hundred
thousand troops stationed on the
ukrainian border we want those troops to
be moved but of course we are preparing
for the worst that's why we've urged all
british citizens to leave ukraine and
we're doing all we can to support the
ukrainian economy we talked or rather we
heard bruce johnson and president biden
a 40-minute chat yesterday on the phone
talking about a crucial window uh what
do they mean by that
well we know or we believe that vladimir
putin has not yet made a decision about
whether to invade ukraine we think it's
highly likely
there are huge numbers of troops lined
up on the border we know that they're in
a position to attack imminently but he
can still change his mind and that is
why diplomacy is so vital making it
clear to russia the cost that would be
of an invasion there would be severe
sanctions and we know the ukrainians
would fight back
we've helped train up 20 000 soldiers
we've provided defensive weapons and the
ukrainians will engage in what will be a
long drawn-out conflict which will be
hugely damaging for russia and the
people of russia
how quickly do we think that president
putin could take kiev if that's his plan
they're on on the northern border
they're only about 140 miles north of
kiev
well we think an attack could be
imminent
of course as i've said the ukrainians
will fight back so this could lead to a
very protracted conflict which would be
hugely damaging for russia but in terms
of the timing of an attack it could be
imminent which is why we're advising all
british citizens to leave ukraine i
understand whilst there is still
commercial routes open i understand
my question is um how quickly do we
think that they could move down to kiev
if they didn't indeed invade or very
very quickly they they have um troops
stationed around around ukraine so there
could be an attack on kiev uh there
could be an attack from the east
uh
and what we also suspect is there could
be a false flag operation
that there could be false claims that
that they have been provoked
to give a pretext uh for russian
invasion and what we have been doing is
we've been calling out the russians
we've been exposing uh their attempts to
put a puppet government into kiev we've
been exposing uh their attempts to
create a pretext but what we do expect
over the next few days is there could be
an attempt of a false flag operation to
create a pretext to claim the ukrainians
are attacking them so that the russians
have a justification
for invading ukraine is there any
evidence of that
there is evidence that that
that is the type of activity they're
looking at and we've seen the russians
do it before this is absolutely from the
russian playbook the use of cyber
attacks the attempts to undermine
the legitimacy of the ukrainian
government and the use of false flag
operations to justify a pretext for
invasion so those are the kinds of
things that we're looking out for
over the next day or so russian defense
minister says that's absolutely nonsense
and that many of the military drills
have already ended um and it looks as
though many of the troops will be moving
back from the borders within days we
can't take them at their word well
why have they stationed a hundred
thousand troops on the ukrainian border
in a deliberately threatening fashion
and why is it the case that they have
the full supplies and preparations to be
able to mount an invasion and they
clearly are seeking to threaten ukraine
they're seeking to bully ukraine they've
been very clear that they have these
demands such as ukraine never being able
to join nato
such as moving ahead with the division
of parts of ukraine so it's very clear
that the russians have
some diplomatic aims which are
essentially reducing ukrainian
sovereignty and self-determination that
is why they've stationed those troops on
the border to seek to threaten nato and
threaten ukraine
and that's why the only thing i will
believe kay
is when they move the troops away from
the border words are easy what they need
to do is move the troops away from the
border do we have any evidence that
they've been trying to end the crisis
well
they started the crisis first of all so
the only reason we are talking about
this today is because of russian
aggression everything nato has done has
been defensive we've been strengthening
the eastern flank because of the
increased aggression that we have seen
from russia and you know we have been
talking to russia i was in
moscow last week the prime minister has
spoken to president putin president
biden has spoken to putin so of course
we want a diplomatic solution but it
can't be at the expense of ukrainian
sovereignty the fact is that in 1994
russia signed up to the budapest
memorandum which agreed that in exchange
for giving up its nuclear weapons
ukraine would have sovereignty and
territorial integrity and russia are now
trying to undermine that but not so any
diplomatic solution has to respect the
sovereignty of ukraine but not to be
members of nato uh and as we know the
ukrainians are very keen to be members
of nato uh which is where the on pass
stands at the moment
ukraine is a sovereign country and it is
a decision for ukraine and nato
about whether or not
ukraine should be a member of nato it's
not a decision for russia russia should
not have a veto over other countries
security arrangements and the big risk
of course
if there is an invasion into ukraine
that will be hugely damaging for russia
and ukraine and it will further
undermine the stability of europe
president putin
has
actively questioned why other countries
in eastern europe are members of nato as
well so this i fear would not stop at
ukraine this is an attack
on
the neighboring states of russia and
other east european countries and trying
to undermine the legitimacy of them
being part of nature but as you know
president putin's view is that nato
promised that it wouldn't move any
further east
when we saw the breakup of uh the soviet
union there was no agreement of that
sort k there is no agreement of that
sort the agreements i've talked about
the budapest 1994 agreement uh the other
agreements that were signed as part of
the osce the security cooperation
agreement none of them mentioned that
countries could not be part of nato in
fact
those agreements are very explicit that
countries should have responsibility for
their own security arrangements and they
should be free to make those
arrangements provided they don't
undermine other countries security and
the fact is
russia's security is not being
undermined nobody believes that russia
is under attack the issue here is that
russia is threatening ukraine by
stationing troops on its border and you
say potentially not stop at ukraine what
do you mean by that
what i mean is if we saw
an invasion into ukraine
there would be severe costs in terms of
a long-running conflict
we could see the undermining of security
more broadly in europe and we could also
see other aggressors around the world
see it as an opportunity
to to expand their ambitions too so this
is a very dangerous moment for the world
this is of course about ukraine which is
an important sovereign nation but it's
also about the wider stability of europe
and it's about wider global stability
and the message that we give to
aggressors and we have to give the
message to vladimir putin that there can
be no reward for aggression there can be
no reward for lining up troops on
somebody else's border and threatening
to invade talk about other countries
which which countries were you talking
about
well i mean we are we're currently in
negotiations with iran uh over stopping
them acquiring a nuclear weapon
in vienna
we've seen
china
increase its economic coercion and
flights over taiwan
we cannot give a message
that aggression
gets rewards what are we going to do
about the british embassy the u.s have
temporarily relocated theirs
we have moved some of our staff
to the west of ukraine
to levieve but we retain a presence in
kiev i'm going to continue with that we
are we are going to continue but of
course we are constantly looking at the
situation ukraine making sure that we
are providing a service for british
nationals at the same time as making
sure our staff are kept safe if
necessary how many uh ukrainian refugees
should we accept
well we're not uh we're not at that
point
at the moment what we are doing is we
are working on humanitarian response
with partners with non-government
organizations and with other countries
and our priority at the moment is
securing the return of british nationals
who want to return there are some
british nationals who want to stay in
ukraine we've made it very clear to them
what the risks are but our priority is
securing the return of british nationals
how difficult is it to negotiate with
the russians they weren't particularly
polite to you when you went
last week lavrov uh being incredibly
rude saying it was a conversation
between a dumb and a deaf person it
seems like we listen but don't hear what
would you say in response to him
well i made it very clear to minister
lavrov and i was also delivering a
message to the russian people
that if there was an invasion into
ukraine there would be severe cost to
russia it would result in a long-running
conflict and it would result in very
tough sanctions that would hit not just
the oligarchs close to putin but also
major companies in russia and of course
sergey lavrov didn't like what i had to
say but i was there in russia to deliver
a message to make it clear to the
russian government there wouldn't be
rewards for aggression and they need to
move their troops away from the border
and the question that he could not
answer that sergey lavrov could not
answer is why there are a hundred
thousand troops on the russian border
with ukraine if they have no plans to
invade you very kindly came uh to see us
a couple of weeks ago uh when you talked
about nordstrom um two and and when you
were referring uh to that you said uh
that uh it completely stops if there's
an invasion we cannot favor short-term
economic interests over the long-term
survival of freedom and democracy in
europe are other germans doing
everything that they can as far as well
chancellor schultz is uh traveling to
moscow today
he's having a meeting with putin
when he was over in the united states
there was a press conference president
biden
made it very clear that nordstrom 2
would not go ahead and i hope that is
the message he is delivering to vladimir
putin today because it is simply
unconscionable
that that would go ahead in the event of
an invasion of ukraine how worried are
you sitting here this morning
i'm very worried about the situation
okay we could be on the brink
of a war in europe which would have
severe consequences
not just for the people of russia and
ukraine but also for the broader
security of europe
there is still time there is still time
for vladimir putin to step away from the
brink but there are there is only a
limited amount of time for him to do
that okay uh just another couple of very
quick thoughts um the met police
yesterday confirming in an investigation
death threats made to kia stammer
following boris johnson's comments about
um jimmy savile this is what kia's
dumbest said yesterday i just want to
get your thoughts on this
the prime minister knew what he was
doing when he
introduced that slur
the other day
but this is not about me
there are threats to too many
politicians particularly women actually
should the prime minister reconsider and
just say sorry
the prime minister did clarify his
remarks and of course
i deeply regret what happened to
kirstalma every politician needs to be
able to go about their job through
without fear that's that's very
important but ultimately it's the
perpetrators who
attacked kyrst armour who verbally
abused kierstarma who we should be
putting the blame on yeah pm darting
between cobra meetings heading up to
scotland going to the north west the
northeast for his leveling up travelling
again to europe um is he ever going to
have time to fill in this questionnaire
for the police
well he is fully cooperating uh with the
police inquiry but as you've rightly
said kay there is a very serious
situation at present
that we've been discussing with russia
and ukraine and the prime minister is
fully focused on that he will be
chairing a meeting of cobra uh later
this morning to make sure that we are
really pursuing the diplomacy that we
are pulling out all the stops on that at
the same time
as preparing for the worst and making
sure we are in the best possible
position to respond alongside our nato
allies i wouldn't want to swap places in
your very elegant shoes this morning
foreign
quick look at how the papers are seeing
that this morning the situation in
ukraine is dominating the front pages as
you can imagine very very dangerous the
guardian has the pm's warning on the
build-up of russian troops as vladimir
putin sends thousands more to the
ukrainian border
the eye leads with what it describes as
last-ditch efforts to avoid war
reporting residents in kiev are
preparing their raid shelters
just say no says the metro they go with
the prime minister urging france and
germany to end their reliance on russian
gas and in the paper's words stand up to
president putin
but the financial times suggests there's
fresh hope in the crisis saying russia's
foreign minister has hinted that
diplomatic efforts should continue
meantime uk fuel prices have hit a new
record high with the ongoing tensions in
ukraine partly to blame let's find out
more should we molena standing by for us
in west london at a petrol station those
prices are rocketing artly melania good
morning
good morning kay there are i mean russia
is the world's third largest producer of
oil and the looming threat of conflict
with ukraine has fueled this price hike
and if president putin does invade
ukraine it will trigger sanctions from
europe and the west and it would make it
harder to supply europe as well as some
of the oil goes to ukrainian pipelines
and if those sanctions also hit the
russian banking sector it will make it
harder for them to export commodities
which could really send the price of oil
skyrocketing and all of that spells
really bad news for drivers in the uk
the rac said that we could see those
price rises set new records in the
coming weeks take a listen to what their
spokesman had to say
oil uh is
likely to go probably higher still
there's a lot of tension uh obviously
between uh russia and ukraine and that
causes a lot of turmoil on the oil
market
and so there's a fear over a shortage of
supply should things escalate there
now this crisis comes off the back of an
already increased demand for oil after
major economies reopened and lifted
covered 19 restrictions and major oil
producers haven't been able to catch up
with that so that compounded with russia
ukraine tension spells a lot more
expensive to fill up your car
okay thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning
just outraged speaking to labour's
shadow employment minister alison
mcgovern
petrol price is rising and an energy
crisis looming just what might be the
future of fossil fuels discussing that
with a couple of experts later this hour
and speaking of the former british
ambassador to russia sir andrew wood to
get his perspective on tensions between
russia and ukraine
before that there's some breaking news
on the cost of living paul standing by
for us hi paul tell us more
yeah morning k we've got the labor
market statistics from the office for
national statistics this morning and we
spent the last year or two looking at
how the employment market has been
coping with covid now we're looking at
the impact on wages and these statistics
give us the
real term wages the money that people
are actually receiving in their pay
packets compared to inflation for the
last quarter of last year so to up to
december now the good news is that pay
including bonuses rose by 4.3 percent uh
to december and regular pay that's
without bonuses uh was up 3.7 the bad
news is that inflation is running at
more than 5
so in real terms that pay
without if you take the regular pay
without any bonuses is down 0.8 so the
real terms impact on the money people
are taking home at the end of the month
or the end of the week is they have less
real terms money to spend and of course
we know the pressures the upward
pressures of inflation and how they're
impacting actually for the for the
quarter of us rather forgive me not for
the quarter for the end of last year
november december actually the picture
is even slightly worse pay down 1.2
in real terms that's your pay packet
compared to inflation with all those
other inflationary pressures the real
concern in the bank of england is that
as wages increase we'll get some
domestic inflation to go with those
international forces like the oil price
we've been talking about
paul is that a guitar behind you
it may well be kay over my uh right
shoulder yes oh okay i didn't know that
you played the guitar what's your
favorite
song many to choose from i think it's
one of the kids guitars actually we're
trying a new shot
okay
you've caught me out my my uh my back of
shot discipline has let me down i know
we love it we love it shows you human
thanks very much paul thank you
i played the guitar do you know
let's look at some of today's other
headlines for you from today covered
restrictions will be scrapped in
northern ireland and replaced with
guidance rules on mask wearing in public
places and coronavirus passes for
nightclubs will now only be recommended
across the uk there have been another 41
648 cases recorded in the last 24-hour
period a further 35 people have died
which takes the total number of people
who have died within 28 days of a
positive covet test to 159
605.
a man in a bar in germany has died after
unknowingly drinking champagne spiked
with ecstasy eight other people had to
be hospitalized after sharing the bottle
when the police arrived at the scene
they found people lying on the ground
with cramps and are now investigating
how the drug got into the bottle
police have warned the public not to
approach a sex offender who's on the run
from an open prison in lincolnshire
they say 56-year-old paul robson who
particularly poses a danger to women and
young children could be anywhere in the
uk he had been refused parole five times
and had been serving a life sentence for
attempted rape and indecent assault
colleen rooney has been denied
permission by a high court judge to
bring a claim against rebecca vardy's
agent it's part of an ongoing legal
battle between the footballer's wives
over an online post mrs rooney had
wanted to bring an additional claim
against ms watt for misuse of private
information
now this morning we'll see 15 year old
russian figure skater camila valeeva
take into the ice again in the winter
olympics after a doping allegations
threatened her chances of competing
let's find out more should we tom is
with us as he is almost every morning hi
tom so she is going to be able to
compete the americans up in arms
morning k yes you will be on the eyes
today around 10 a.m uh your time 6 p.m
beijing time a lot of people are unhappy
with that the
american olympic association the u.s
olympic and paralympic uh committee said
they're extremely disappointed with this
just to remind you how we got here this
was a sample in december 25th december
that tested positive the test only came
through on the 8th of february uh the
ioc wanted to prevent her from competing
but she won her appeal at the court for
a court of arbitration for sport and
will be allowed to compete um we've
heard some more details today from an
ioc official saying uh that apparently
the argument she presented was the
contamination happened with a product
that her grandfather was using this was
a medicine used to treat angina and
that's what was presented at this
hearing but it is worth remembering this
hearing wasn't about that test it was
just about whether the suspension was
appropriate and they pointed to her
status as a protected person someone
who's less than 16 years old what that
means in effect is they want the
investigation to run its course but they
don't think it's fair to deprive her of
the chance to compete in these olympics
if that investigation finds that she was
cleared or that it's only a minor
reprimand because as a protected person
there are slightly different sanctions
in terms of what can be applied to
athletes but that has left a lot of
people upset and it's put the ioc in a
very awkward position they're not going
to be handing out medals tonight if she
finishes in the top three that's just a
reminder of how complicated this whole
situation is
okay thanks tom thank you on the ice a
little bit uh later on today now i want
to get up to show you this if you ever
wanted to visit
one of the wonders of the world this
is uh one of them
but
it's a bit like that this is the taj
mahal but not as you know it made
entirely out of snow it stands at just
4.9 metres high 14 times smaller than
the original four sculptors took only 17
days to complete it and just like its
counterpart it's proving very popular
with tourists in gul mag i was going to
be able to say to you compared to how
long it took to build the original one
but i don't know how long it took to the
original one so what i'm going to do
instead is tell you about the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar
airways storm dudley will bring
potentially damaging winds from
wednesday into thursday while storm
eunice will arrive on friday the met
office has issued an amber wind warning
for northern ireland southern scotland
and northern england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
i should also say there's a wind warning
for donegal if you're watching us this
morning very good morning to britain's
oldest zoo is due to permanently close
this autumn bristol zoo gardens which
has existed for 186 years will shut its
doors in september meaning all animals
are set to move to a new home the wild
place project in south gloucestershire
so closing after declining attendance
was made worse by the pandemic parts of
the site will become housing but the
gardens will remain open to the public
if you are as old as i am and you
remember animal magic on the telly
based on that now have a look at this
how did you spend your valentine's day
well these doggies in peruvian capital
of lima celebrated the day in style by
getting hitched or part of a local
competition dog owners dressed up their
four-legged friends as if they were
about to get married uh they were
walking down the aisle then helped to
sign their inked paws into a piece of
paper
just
pause for thought
i'm here all week try the veal coming up
after the break former british
ambassador to russia sir andrew wood
gives his perspective to the ongoing
tensions between russia and ukraine
[Music]
hello again very good morning to you the
foreign secretary has told us that she's
worried that we could be on the brink of
war in europe those tensions in ukraine
continue
prime minister will have more on that of
course so he's attending a cobra meeting
shortly meantime tensions on the ukraine
border have begun impacting the uk as
the cost of fuel hits a record high
plus increasing prices and decreasing
pay wage growth practically wiped out
when adjusted for the highest inflation
in 30 years
we could be on the brink of war in
europe that's the message from the
government this morning as they say
there's only a short window for
diplomacy to de-escalate tensions in
ukraine earlier the foreign secretary
told us she hoped putin would step back
from putting more russian troops on the
border
how quickly do we think that they could
move down to kiev if they didn't indeed
invade or very very quickly they they
have
troops stationed around around ukraine
so there could be an attack on kiev uh
there could be an attack from the east
uh
and what we also suspect is there could
be a false flag operation i'm very
worried uh about the situation okay we
could be on the brink
of a war in europe which would have
severe consequences
not just for the people of russia and
ukraine but also for the broader
security of europe
there is still time there is still time
for vladimir putin to step away from the
brink but there are there is only a
limited amount of time for him to do
that
joe's here with us this morning good
morning good morning she was very sombre
wasn't she she was i think she was
communicating kay to different audiences
firstly with this message this wider
message of danger talking about being on
the brink of an invasion that russia
could invade um ukraine and get to kiev
pretty quick quickly but a second
message that we saw her her approaching
there i think ultimately to vladimir
putin talking about the danger to
russia's place in the world the danger
to the russian economy because of course
as we know from
recent examples in the middle east an
invasion might be quick but
what happens next can be far more long
protracted and very very expensive we
know that boris johnson is chairing
cobra today i'm sure his trust will be
uh part of that he'll be going to europe
later in the week he wants to be seen as
does liz trust at the center of all of
this ultimately
it's one man vladimir putin who does
need to make a decision
she's intimating today that a decision
may not have been made and we'll be
looking okay at that 3 p.m ish news
conference between mr putin and the
german chancellor olaf schultz for any
signs in particular on that
controversial issue of nord stream to
this gas pipeline so could that
potentially uh splinter the um bond in
in europe because of course the uk
definitely want germany to cancel that
yeah i think it already potentially is
starting to drive a wedge splinter is a
good word okay
because it is uh clearly uh economically
beneficial to germany this gas pipeline
from russia into europe
through the baltics and um it is
controversial because it means that the
way that germany approaches russia is in
a far softer uh place style than many
other european partners and i know
you've got a take for us at nine o'clock
you'll take at nine o'clock looking
forward to that thanks very much indeed
meantime let's get more uh joined by sir
andrew wood who served as the uk's
ambassador to russia between 1995 and
2000 so would have worked uh when in
russia in moscow when president putin
was there of course um
how easy to deal with uh mr ambassador
good morning
good morning um
i think he's got worse as the years have
gone by he certainly has in terms of the
way he governs russia
which is one of the worries at the back
of my mind
that if he does succeed in conquering uh
ukraine as it were
then his tyrannical rule there will be
enhanced
for a short period
right yeah what motivates him
well there's a strong uh
growing hatred of of the west and
patriots pressed not the right word but
mistrust of the west and believes that
the west
is
targeted against him against his country
the
other factor is that he wishes russia to
be a great power which means a great
military power
i think a great power to govern well as
well for example but that's not what he
thinks be a great military power is
critical to him
how worried are you
we heard from the foreign secretary she
says she's very worried uh that we were
on the brink of war in europe but um i
suppose the flip side of that is that
president uh putin has a track record
for military deception um
where do you think we are
well there is an element of military
deception in this in the you don't mass
troops around people's borders without
that being meant to intimidate
whether or not he goes on to military
assault is something different that's
more dangerous for him it will certainly
be resisted in in ukraine
would also mean that if he managed to
seize ukraine as it were
he would also be seizing a nation which
has come to dislike him
um
very deeply
there is a difference between disliking
him and disliking russia
there is a fellow feeling to some degree
between ukraine and russia
but
that's also a long history of ukraine
being
persecuted in a sense by russia under
stalin and so on
so it's a big mix
what more could britain have done
i don't think britain could have done
much more given the
state of our armed forces and the extent
of them anyway and the state is pretty
good but the extent of them uh given
that we very much depend on a
a united
view in europe
which i think we've managed to help to
cultivate
but given particularly that we managed
to uh
stir up when the startup's not the right
word consolidate
a feeling in eastern europe that russia
must be resisted
i'm not sure much else we could do about
that
the parade of senior politicians from
europe traveling
to moscow to try to placate president
putin and his foreign secretary um it's
certainly interesting we know that the
german leader is is there again today to
talk to president putin uh but when our
foreign secretary went she was basically
humiliated by lavrov what was all that
about
rob is is that sort of man
and it's actually in some ways it was a
compliment that we've been rather more
direct and uh
implicatory
than others
i don't think there's any prospect of
placating putin in that sense
what is after it
is control over ukraine
because ukraine is a
a threat to him in the sense that it is
trying to
run a
democratic and reasonable societies we
would think
and he would wish it was his
country to control
and his his country would be controlled
by a
a regime in ukraine which wouldn't be
democratic at all at all
so i don't think yeah
yeah just looking at a wonderful picture
actually of moscow i'm sure that you
remember that scene
very well indeed from your tenure there
um we are threatening
the the russian um the russian
government and president putin and his
friends and allies with economic
sanctions do you think that will make
any difference
well it will have an effect
whether it will
an effect
after invasion for how long i don't know
they would certainly have to be kept up
for a long time
i think biggest effect on what might
happen to the regime in russia
comes from the russian people themselves
the russian people
do not want
war unless it's very quick and
successful
they do not at all like the idea that
they're going to be fighting ukrainians
again a quick victory then
but the propaganda has put out is that
ukraine is a threat to russia
the absurd
notion that russia will be attacked
across its borders by ukraine
um
is laughable nobody in their right mind
is going to walk in against a hundred
thousand troops the other side
yeah just looking at images as well of
of kiev we we know that uh some russian
troops are only 120 miles away from the
ukrainian border this morning as we
speak you talk about the russian people
there not wanting a long protracted war
but one wonders how strong their voice
is when they have um a leadership uh
like president putin
no their voices is annulled
nonetheless putin has to
retain some respect and uh support
beyond the security police
if he is uh to be able to run a
uh an obedient people if you like
there have been huge
demonstrations before
there's no reason to suppose that there
will necessarily be none
later that that is i'm just expressing a
feeling rather than anything else
is it
under putin's rather a dead country in
that sense yes
mr ambassador is always fascinating to
talk to i hope life on jersey is
treating you well thank you very much
indeed
yesterday saw the price of fuel reach
its highest ever level now with many
feeling that fossil fuels can't be the
solution to the energy crisis we're
facing what kind of future does it have
let's talk about it should we join us is
dale vince the founder of green energy
supply ecotricity and stuart hazeldean a
professor of carbon capture at the
university of edinburgh hello to you
both thank you very much indeed for
joining us on the programme this morning
uh let's start with you dale first of
all should we we're seeing uh prices at
the pumps uh well over 155 a litre this
morning how much longer can we rely on
fossil fuels
uh well
we can't rely on them at all and
obviously they're getting injured are
seen to all kinds of problems not the
least of which is the climate crisis
this current energy crisis
obviously has fossil fuels at the heart
of it we're utterly dependent on global
markets for fossil fuels and we allow
global markets to set the price of
fossil fuels even when we extract them
from our own north sea so that's all
kinds of wrong and we have to just
break the link between us and fossil
fuels for so many reasons
um professor uh tell me about carbon
capture how does it work and how can it
help
well i'll agree with dale actually that
we do need to break the link with fossil
fuels and we need to get out of fossil
fuels as fast and as comprehensively as
we can
but we also have to realize that
probably could take many tens of years
even for this country and globally we
have to bring around the world with us
and so carbon capture is a way of trying
to uh
reduce the effect of fossil fuels whilst
we're still using them it's a way of
trying to
extract the energy but capture the
harmful carbon dioxide which is the
driver for the climate change which we
all want to avoid as much as possible
because we are in a climate emergency
and so
the future in my uh recommendation lies
with trying to reduce our use of fossil
fuels but whenever we do use fossil
fuels we should be fitting carbon
capture to capture that carbon dioxide
and store that safely and securely for
tens of thousands of years deep below
the ground to put the carbon back where
it came from
um dale the energy minister greg hans
telling the times that britain must keep
drilling for gas in the north sea for
reasons of energy security what would
you say in response to that
i think it's madness you know and it's
bordering on the illiterate to say
something like that because the north
sea hasn't given us energy security we
allowed global markets to set the price
for that we paid 10 times as much
for gas from our own north sea in the
last few months than we did a year ago
and there's no reason for that hasn't
cost more to extract so making our own
fossil fuels does not give us energy
price security we aren't actually short
of fossil fuels anyway so we don't need
that form of security either what we
need to do
is to
[Music]
take fossil fuels out of our energy mix
all together the way for us to be truly
energy independent is to harness the
wind and the sun our own renewable
technologies we can power the country 20
times over from our own means and we can
break the link
to global prices for energy completely
we can have permanently low and stable
energy bills we can solve energy poverty
and give a massive boost to our economy
and it won't take decades we could do
this in 10 years and the idea that
carbon capture and storage is the answer
is a myth it's a myth perpetuated by the
fossil fuel industry and investors in
fossil fuels who have finally come
around to acknowledging that climate
change is a problem and fossil fuels are
the cause and now they turn themselves
to a different tactic which is delay
they're saying yes we get it we get it
but of course we depend on fossil fuels
and it's going to take time to wean
ourselves off i say that it won't it'll
take 10 years and we just need to get on
with it we pull billions more into the
north sea in the way of subsidies that
we take back out in the way of tax and
that situation just has to end we need
to put our money into renewable energy
um and professor i wondered if you could
talk to me about the suggestion from the
government quite recently in in one of
the i think it was a white paper saying
that they want to see 600 000 heat pumps
low carbon alternative of course to gas
boilers
installed per year by
2028 which is just around the corner
likelihood of that uh well i think
that's a great ambition but it's really
difficult to achieve in practice because
uh
firstly you've got to have the
people who are available to fit those
and expertly fit those so they work and
size those appropriately for the houses
and also it's clear that in many houses
extra insulation is needed in extra
energy saving measures which we should
be doing anyway as fast as possible
and also in many cases the size of the
radiators needs to be increased inside
the house so it's slightly more
difficult than
than just turning up in a van and having
it done by the early afternoon but i do
think we should be moving in that
direction we've got some of the worst
housing and buildings in europe for
energy inefficiency we waste huge
amounts of energy
and actually i think if we're going to
carry on working with oil companies we
need to control them a lot more so a
condition
of continuing to extract oil and gas
from the ground should be that we make
the oil companies pay for the cleanup we
let them get away with dumping the
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
and that causes climate change for
everybody around the world which is our
responsibility and we're not enforcing
the cleanup on those companies so i
would
create a mandate that companies
extracting carbon from the ground have
to store an exactly equivalent amount of
carbon back into the ground and that
could be enacted really simply and
really quickly within years and so we
need a multiple track approach we need
the wind power we need the solar power
we need energy efficiency we need to
change our ways of heating and we need
to control the fossil fuel companies and
make them work for us rather than us
working for them
okay fascinating stuff guys thanks so
much for taking the time this tuesday
morning thank you
thanks
i want to talk about ukraine in a bit
more detail satellite images taken in
the past few days show missile batteries
and a field hospital in belarus and
crimea despite the buildup of its troops
russia maintains it is
nato which is the aggressor so where is
everybody where are the troops um what
does what's the threat to ukraine uh
where is kiev in relation to where the
russian troops are who better to tell
you than ali
first up i want to show you two maps
that in part explain the situation we
find ourselves in today the first shows
nato expansion all the way from the
founding of the washington treaty in
1949 up until 2020 when north macedonia
the latest member joined and you can see
the soviet empire shrinking and nato
expanding eastward and that is what
annoys vladimir putin he believes nato
poses a direct threat to russian
security but let's look at the second
nap and this is in a way nato's counter
to that they say that nato only borders
1 16
of russia i've highlighted the borders
there that they share
up in the north in norway the baltic
states and then around the enclave of
klinengrad and if we zoom out to a wide
of that map and see that vast russian
border you can see just how little of it
actually is bordered by nato countries
so what about the latest on the ground
as far as we know it well russian troops
continue to grow in number and encircle
the ukraine there they are in the north
in belarus on exercise we've also
actually got some
down south in moldova as well we think
about a hundred and thirty thousand now
and as i say growing let's look at two
satellite images now this is the sort of
thing that military officials will look
at in order to try and ascertain what's
happening and what might happen next
this is crimea where we see a missile
battery we have another satellite image
that we picked out that shows a field
hospital in belarus all the indications
includes of a possible imminent invasion
how might that invasion look well the
feeling amongst western intelligence
officials is that they will move quickly
to try and take the capital kiev and
decapitate the political military
leadership you've also got ukraine's
best forces that have been stationed in
the east of the country so they would
try
and cut them off and stop them coming
back to the capital
the belief is that president putin has
not yet given the order to invade but a
go
no go decision
is imminent
that's the latest from alastair of
course we'll keep an eye on that for you
meantime stoner henge um top of our
bucket list of places to see in the uk
before we die so says a new survey the
prehistoric stone circle beat the
brighton pavilion and hadrian's wall to
the top spot
[Music]
i know i want to sing along as well
[Music]
so
do you know where these chalky cliffs
come up they go underneath the um
channels you know where they come up in
france
champagne region which is why champagne
grapes taste the way they do
there you go
uh meantime what else have we got for
you
stonehenge there they go they were top
of the list there you go
if you've not been you're really sure
they've got a very good visitor center
there as well
and here we've got time bridge
there we are um vlog on the tine and all
of that i used to work just about here
in addition to that we got the london
eye
built for the millennium of course that
was um
opened
at the end of december 1999.
the angel of the north i can't remember
who did that somebody probably can if
you can can you send me a tweet and
remind me at k burley you can see it
can't you as you go up the a1m towards
newcastle and finally
got one more giant causeway here we go
i've never been tell me what it's like
uh see you at the top of the hour what
on earth is happening in ukraine
[Music]